[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
a scene from the film adaptation of the
Chamber of Secrets that left a lot of
people very confused
we know Dobby as the house elf who
serves the Malfoy family and for years
they treated him poorly but he was their
servant he had no choice but on one
fateful day
Harry freeze Dobby and he becomes a free
elf Harry freed Dobby for several
reasons but the primary motivation for
Harry is that he knew that Dobby was
miserable serving the Malfoy's it was no
secret that Dobby wanted to be free and
Harry sought as the morally right thing
to do
Harry devised a clever trick in which he
planned to get Lucius to hand or be a
diary the sock hidden inside a gift of
clothing that broke Bobby's enslavement
this opportunity also gave Harry a
meaningful and tangible way of thanking
and rewarding Dobby for putting himself
at risk to help Harry freeing Dobby
angered Lucius in depriving the esteemed
Malfoy family of a servant added insult
to injury
Harry was able to free Dobby by placing
Riddle's diary inside his sock Lucius
then disgustedly ripped the sock off of
the book and threw the sock into the air
which Dobby then caught making him a
free elf lucious's response to Dobby
being freed is absurdly over-the-top at
least in the film noticeably outraged
Lucius pulls out his wand and begins to
state the incantation of a spell Avada
but before he can complete his
incantation Dobby steps in and zaps him
so what spell was Lucius going to cast a
vada hmm what suppose do we know that
start with a vada oh yeah the killing
curse as far as I know there are no
other spells that start with the vada
and Avada Kedavra is not only the
killing curse but one of the
unforgivable curses was Lucius really
about to kill Harry a twelve-year-old in
broad daylight
just outside of the Hogwarts
Headmaster's office / Dobby being freed
the book of course describes this scene
differently as Lucius only lunges at
Harry which makes a lot more sense the
exchange is shown here Lucius Malfoy
stood
frozen staring at the elf then he lunged
at Harry you've lost me my servant boy
but Dobby shouted you shall not harm
Harry Potter there was a loud bang and
mr. Malfoy was thrown backward but we
can't ignore that in the film version
Lucius Malfoy did seem intent on
murdering Harry Lucius Malfoy it was a
pureblood wizard that came from the
famous Malfoy family he was the father
of Draco and son of Abraxas while
attending Hogwarts he was said to have
been exceptionally gifted at potions
earning the attention of Horace Slughorn
though Lucius was a loyal Death Eater
for many years him and his family
eventually defected while he was a Death
Eater and a bit of a sleazebag I'm still
not convinced that he would be stupid
enough to use the killing curse on a
young boy outside of the Headmaster's
office he has shown on numerous
occasions that he is sneaky calculating
and conniving but capable of murdering a
child in this circumstance I don't think
so
Lucius was also one of the most
important Death Eaters still at large
having convinced the ministry that he
only served follow mort while under the
Imperius curse to kill Harry at this
time would have compromised his
undercover position and this would have
exposed him a supremely foolish Act the
only way that I can see Lucius
rationalizing his behavior would be if
he felt that he could somehow convince
the ministry that it was dobby's doing
that Dobby was somehow responsible for
Harry being hit with the killing curse
one thing is undeniable
Lucius had strong influence in the
ministry and by leveraging this
influence he could have either claimed
that he was acting in self-defense or
that like I mentioned earlier Dobby was
responsible at the end of the day this
is one of those blunders between the
books and films where the filmmaker took
things a little bit too far Chris
Columbus who directed the film is great
and I love a little bit of dramatic
effects but in this instance it was
unnecessary and totally illogical and
that's it for this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you enjoy the content
please remember to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]